Hey ! J'ai reçu une lettre d'un abonné.
Ça me fait super plaisir !
*Musique*
Ah d'accord ! Il y a tous ça aussi ! D'accord...
J..J'avais pas euuuuuuuh, tilté...
*Musique de Noël....*
Évidemment, pile-poil, le jour où je tourne une vidéo.
Je suis complètement malade....
Hein. J'ai donc actuellement la voix de Garou.
♫C'est faux♫
[Garou - Sous le vent ft. Céline Dion]
OOOOooooh !
Petit moutoooooooon !
Ah ouai d'accord, j'ai ma tête dessus ! J'avais pas vu !
*biz*
J't'aime !
Petite coque... d'IPhone.
Hop !
Petite coque, euuuh, bien propre...
Merci mon pote !
Elle va parfaitement à mon portable !
Et apparemment... Elle protège bien...
*Explosion*
'tain !
On a du gâteau...
FAUX !
On a du gâteau : Maintenant j'ai google.
Je pense que dès que je vais ramener une.. une meuf chez moi, j'vais faire :
Hé.... tu veux un gâteau "J'suis dans la friendzone" ? *rire*
Alors ça... C'est extrêmement beau !
Je suppose que la personne qui a fait ça et complètement en maternelle...
Dont le talent est présent...
*rire* Un faux chèque d'un million d'euros *rire*
Ouais, il s'est fait plaisir le gars...
Quitte à que ce soit faux, d'autant que ça soit des grosses sommes.
J'ai quand même essayé d'l'encaisser parce que...
"Salut, ta tête est drôle mais pas toi !"
"Non, c'est une blague. Tout est nul chez toi."
*rire*
*Viole de carton*
Le m. Ah ! J'ai niqué un truc....
Ah !! Excellent !
Psartek, euuuuh, l'équipe...
Donc du maquillage pour représenter cette équipe de Hockey que sont les : Boxers !
Je suis actuellement un indien.
Merde *en riant*
Bon bah les mecs, le mug n'a pas tenu, hein.... Le mug, si tu veux, euuuuh, fonctionne plus...
"Salut Norman, je m'appelle Guillerm. Je suis un grand fan et je voulais te dire que t'es le meilleur YouTuber"
Merci mon pote
Le gars a tapé à l'ordinateur quoi. Le mec est... il est sérieux quoi.
*Tripotage d'une peluche*
Pas... pas de bruit... fait pas de bruit je... j'appuie pour rien.... J'appuie pour rien euuuh.
♪papier♪
oooooh ! Putain !
Aaaaa !
"Mon chat ressemble à Sergi sauf que elle est née avec une petite queue..."
Beuuh alors ?
Beuuh elle n'a qu'une petite queue et c'est pas... c'est pas grave !
Un message à tout les chats qui ont des petites queues, c'est pas grave, d'accord.. Et pareil pour les hommes !
Trop stylééé !
La petite poupée *rire* avec un max de bouclette...
'Tain elle est vachement bien faite...
En dirais une poupée vaudou...
*Jeu d'acteur* Aïe !
Aïe !
Aah !
...
*rire* Arrête ! *rire*
"Cadeau qui m'a coûté cher donc fais-en bonne usage. Signé : Nzola racaille de la Street "
Voilà... c'est la racaille de la street...
*Jean Claude Van Dam*
Bonjour Théophile !
- Ouai, qui est là ?
C'est Norman Thavaud à l'appareil !
*FriendZone*
*rire*
Putain, mais les gens, t'sais quoi, ils prennent du temps pour me faire de très très beau dessin...
Merci d'avoir investi du temps dans ce dessin
1€ !
1€ ! On peut se prendre un caddie ! Euu à E.Leclerc...
Un caillou...
Le mec m'offre un caillou.... euuuuh, bah écoute *rire*
J'vais le mettre dans mon jardin, d..dans mes graviers quoi...
"Pour tes jolies cernes" *rire*
Génial.
*rire*
Un crème anti-cerne...
C'est mieux ou pas ?
*rire* y a plus d'cernes, ça y es !
- Ouuuuuu !
Norman : Alors là !
- Aaaah
Norman : OH NAAAN ! On est déçu hein....
Y a pas d'IPhone
C'des p'tites cartes Pokémon avec des YouTubers dessus...
Y a la carte de MisterV.... Et la carte Cortex...
Draaaa, Dreeee, Draaaaa !
Une bombe de peinture...
Ah c'est l'arnaque !
*screamer*
C'y quoi ?
Putain, merde....
*screamer champagne*
Bouuh ! L'esprit d'la fête !
Pffff *rire*
*rire*
aa, Génial... Et vous.. Et vous m'régalez avec vos cadeaux...
Sarah et Bénédicte... Merci les filles !
Pour cette casquette bite !
Ah ouaiii !
Un petit collage, euuuuh, trop stylé avec toutes mes vidéos 'dans
Ah ouai, vous aimez vraiment le monde de la bite hein...
Les claques doigts d'Antoine..
- *blablablabla*
Ah mais c'est pas fort ça...
*explosion*
Aaaaah !
- Allô ?
Salut Brice !
- Oui ?
C'est Norman !
*rire* Le mec s'en fout...
Euuuh, merci pour te..ta lettre ! Tu m'as envoyé une lettre n'est-ce pas ? Et un dessin...
- Oh oui !
Et ben je te remercie beaucoup !
- Tu m'appelles ?!
C'est cool...
Merci mon pote !
- Oh trop bien !
- Ah tu vois, là chui... dans un espace culturel et j'ai  de retrouver ton DVD
Oooh, c'trop mignon ! Merci Brice !
"Apprête-toi à avoir un orgasme..."
*Musique chaude ;)*
...Gustatif, ouai...
"Ce biscuit est nul, FAUX !
Et, t'sais quoi ? Dès que je vais inviter des gens, j'vais m'la péter avec mes gâteaux faux...
Je huuurle !
C'est, extrêmement bien réalisé !
C'est Black and White !
Yeah ! Luigi Babe !
*rire*
Des lunettes décapsuleur !
*rire* Putain !
Yeaaaah !
Et en plus tu peux le faire avec 2 bouteilles !
Un p'tit bracelet faux !
Avec, en plus derrière, un petit Norman dessiné !... Trop mignon !
La puissance !
On m'a offert un certificat d'adoption d'un corail, genre un truc officiel !
Je participe à la protection d'la planète ! .... Sans avoir rien faire du tout !
Ah ouai, elles sont vraiment ouf celle-là...
Génial ! Génial ce mot...
En tout cas, je continue à ouvrir vos... vos p'tits papiers, ça m'fait hyper plaisir ! J'les montre pas tous à la caméra...
Parfois c'est tout simple mais ça va droit au cœur
"Tu es l'étron de ma vie, la matière fécale du bonheur, si un jour je te vois, tu illumineras mon caca..."
"Norman, veux-tu m'épouser ?"
Peut-être un jour dans le futur lointain, hein Daphné...
Qui est d'ailleurs le prénom de ma sœur...
Hein voilà donc c'est, euuu, *rire* c'est une double gênance hein...
"Bonjour Norman, Cela fait longtemps que je t'observe par la fenêtre de ta cuisine.. Je vais rester anonyme.."
- Allô ?
Bonjour personne anonyme !
- Allô ??
Oui bonjour, c'est Norman :
- A.. Allô ??? A... All... Ah mais nan ! Ah mais nan...
Ça va ?
... C'est... C'est le répondeur ! Euuh, Ah ouai...
- C'est le répondeur... et beh zut alors...  Allez biz !
Ce dessin est très très beau !
Vraiment très très beau euuh... j'aime tout.
Une serviette hygiénique....
*rire*
Bon bah je l'utiliserai quand j'aurai mes règles...
Ah ! Une lettre un peu plus officiel !
"Facture EDF"
Ah mais non, ça s'est... ça s'est pas...
J'ai absolument tout ouvert !
Toutes les lettres... tout les colis... j'ai tout regardé ! C'est vrai David ou pas ?
- C'est exacte !
*rire*
Voilà j'ai fini mon déballage de lettres et colis. On a passé la journée dessus. Merci vraiment à toutes et à tous...
... pour toutes vos petites attentions, toutes vos lettres, euu, tout vos messages, on a vraiment tout regardé... et ça m'a fait extrêmement plaisir... ça me donne, euuh...
...encore plus envie de continuer, bah les vidéos, euuh, j'étais un peu moins présent en 2016 parce que j'ai, j'ai... complètement fini...
... la tournée de mon spectacle, qui est désormais, bah, terminé. En 2017, je vais pouvoir me concentrer...
... à nouveau sur les vidéos et donc en faire un peu plus, ça c'est cool....
J'vous souhaite de très bonnes fêtes de fin d'année, mettez un p'tit pouce en l'air si vous avez kiffer ! Et on se revoie très bientôt les amis. TCHAO !
*Musique de Noël d'outro*